bonjour donc nous allons parler de
musique de direction d'orchestre de
d'artistes qui sont des individualités
souvent extrêmement tu investis d ego
souvent blessé qui va se mettre au
service du d'un groupe d'un collectif
alors qu'est-ce qui lui même doit se
mettre au service d'une oeuvre d'une
offre d'un chef-d'oeuvre de l'humanité
une symphonie et sert alors qu'est ce
qui fait que cette harmonie cette
harmonisation comment ça marche et
surtout qu'est ce que ça implique dans
l'être humain et surtout c'est un modèle
qui peut surtout se répercuter sur
toutes les organisations humaines alors
pressé de com de d'appréhender des
choses qui sont mises en jeu je propose
qu'on aille directement aux exercices
pratiques
je suis le chef d'orchestre vous êtes
les musiciens c'est assez sympa dirige
un orchestre de 400 musiciens donc
allons-y
vous allez faire un truc très simple on
va partir sur le son de base que tout le
monde peut faire c'est à dire voilà
alors voilà vous avez compris
sauf que maintenant on alors première
première chose je les suive le chef donc
par exemple ça fait ça
pas mal
pensez bien que il ya toujours une
préparation
c'est une respiration cette alliance
c'est un commun pas si vous voulez il y
a le moment et le son il ya une
respiration
voilà donc toujours un son un acte se
prépare par un mouvement est tard une
respiration l'on comprend le temps et le
ce on arrive ici
voilà près on peut regarder alors ça c
est pour la consigne vous allez à peu
près pigé donc là on va dire on est sur
la consigne nord-sud n'a manqué comme ça
donc suivi du chef maintenant deuxième
chose deuxième paramètre très important
c'est qu'on doit être ans priori tenter
d'être ensemble
donc là on était uniquement dans une
vision qui était on suit la consigne
donc juste d'individus a consigné
maintenant comment on fait pour le
groupe donc on va reprendre ces petites
choses là et cette fois vous allez
écouter savoir est-ce qu'on est ensemble
ou pas ensemble au moment où on fait ça
bien ce qu'on fait orchestre est ce
qu'on fait groupe on est juste 400
individus en relation avec une consigne
au centre ouvrons les oreilles vous me
suivez toujours
c'est pas mal est-ce qu'on est ensemble
vraiment ce qu'on était ensemble
vraiment si on veut vraiment aller
jusqu'au bout de la démarche si on était
complètement ensemble on devrait
entendre qu'un seul club
pour l'instant on ne peut pas dire que
on entende peut-être pas 400 mais j'en
entends au moins 168 essayons de réduire
ce quota de clap pour rentrer un peu
plus dans dans le groupe s'il vous plaît
j'attire juste votre attention sur vous
sentez que l'espace à changer la vie
d'un seul coup deux individus individus
disponibles au groupe
et bien sûr le coup c'est l'air qui
devient palpable et le groupe qui se
transforme juste part je suis présent je
suis disponible et je peux donner car
dont 5 on va approfondir cette dimension
là parce que c'est celle vacon la plus
importante
on pourrait presque être un concert là
je marque je vois rien moi je vois je ne
vous vois pas falloir jeux distincts
quelques silhouettes
moi je vois une aura et cette oreille
commence à se construire
ce qui est intéressant là c'est que d'un
seul coup vous avez ouvert nos oreilles
et ça a été beaucoup moins fort le rendu
sonore terre que dès qu'on écoute
l'autre on va tout de suite beaucoup
moins d' écraser et donc dans quand on
est dans un rapport direct on veut
exister moi j'existe
dès qu'on veut enfin commencé à
s'intéresser à l'autre on va exister un
tout petit peu moins et on va le laisser
exister
donc automatiquement le son change et la
production sonore uniquement vous avez
pas dis je je vais frappé moins fort non
j'écoute l'autre et donc immédiatement
la frappe est moins forte et en plus est
partie des harmonies qui commence à
venir faire que on n'est pas sur des
sons comme ça on est beaucoup plus sur
les sons comme ça qu'ils sont
harmoniquement même sur des choses
extrêmement basique beaucoup plus riche
en terme de couleurs sonores alors on
approfondit là c'est bon j'entends des
plus que 80 de kla sur 400 c'est bien on
est en nette progression
si on pouvait arriver à deux ou trois ça
serait on y va donc là la question c'est
les yeux autant que les oreilles c'est à
dire qu'après nord-sud ont fait est
ouest ok donc ça veut dire que pour
pouvoir être véritablement ensemble
la deuxième dimension absolument
incontrôlable c'est les oreilles et on
doit sentir ensemble que on doit voir
distinguer tout l'éclat tous des
musiciens d'un côté si on veut être avec
eux on doit être en contact avec eux le
contact et des oreilles
alors ça c'est un phénomène qui est tout
à fait humain c'est-à-dire que dès qu'on
se sent observé dès qu'on se sent écouté
dès qu'on se sent regarder on stresse et
comme en stress on devance donc y en a
toujours qui je veux tout va bien y en a
bien qui est filmé ici c'est moi ok vous
vous êtes dans le noir
pas de stress vous n'avez pas va
anticipé la consigne juste bien ça
marche à tous les coups il y en a
toujours un qui fait ça alors c'est je
fais ça beaucoup et que les élèves à la
classe d'orchestre
ils ont un gage
il paye la tournée de bonbons après ça
les calme il ya aussi un truc c'est que
dès qu'on met en place un quelque chose
de répétitif on s'installe tout de suite
dans une habitude ça c'est fou après on
s'étonne pourquoi la sécu ils ont pas
envie de mais quand on fait la même
chose toute la journée on veut ans on se
dit toujours la même chose rentrer chez
soi en fait la même chose au clash v12 3
je m'arrête y en a toujours un qui fait
4 ben ali parce que comme on a fait
trois fois de la 3c déjà une habitude
donc comment faire trois trucs de suite
sans que ça devienne une habitude c'est
à dire rester disponible à ce que si
après le 3 ça s'arrête et ben y'a pas de
4 comment s'extraire de l'habitude pour
rester disponible à l'instant présent
ah ça va deux c'est déjà le début d'une
habitude vous avez vu ça comment bien
vite fonctionnaires voilà donc vous
savez ça va très très vite
vous imaginez pas alors alors maintenant
comment on fait vous avez pu voir là on
a déjà bien réduit on a bien réduit la
qualité de frappe
on est plus à 400 on n'est plus qu'à dix
mois on a bien réduit mais en fait on se
rend compte sur l'approfondît les choses
quand on fera une journée tous ensemble
on aura le temps d'aller y reste plus
que quelques minutes
qu'est ce qui fait qu on est vraiment
ensemble ça n'est pas seulement que être
ensemble dans le temps in time et ça
c'est très important je prendre à khobar
d'y aller c'est michel qui était l'année
michel allé michel c'est parti alors
voilà on va on va faire un inventaire un
exercice d'ascq en fait moi on est
nombreux
finalement plus c'est difficile d'être
ensemble
jean-michel plus c'est difficile d'être
ensemble pourquoi parce que quand on est
très nombreux il ya forcément phénomène
de masse qui gomme un peu le détail des
cons et 2,6 en à un hacker obtiennent
légère chose alors on va essayer
d'étudier restera bien au centre c'est
la consigne gâté d'axis fois tous en
tous genres sont rouges tous à la
lumière temps vous allez faire ça
relativement sonore musicalement et moi
je vais vous suire et je vais essayer
d'être parfaitement avec vous pour qu'on
entende plus qu'1 seul son au lieu des
206 ont fait ensemble comme ça sans
faire attention allons-y en grèce on
reste sur le lac pulsations simple elle
est technique tout de suite un des
jeunes mais décroche et des noirs on
voit tout de suite des gens qui veulent
aller plus loin que l'horizon qui leur
est proposé voilà donc au fait ça quand
vous entendez bien deux personnes est
d'accord on est bien deux
on vante en gagnent 2 on a beau être en
shanghai en détention vous attendez bien
deux son ensemble j'entends des deux
paires de mains et pas une seule
regardez la différence tout seul accusé
a dit michel n'ayez pas le trac deux
hoquets entend bien la différence
donc j'imagine et quand on a 400 membres
donc maintenant comment je vais faire
moi si je veux me fondre dans la
sonorité si je veut harmoniser ma frappe
pour que on entendre dans leurs caisses
quand vous avez 16 premiers violons qui
joue exactement la même partition on
n'entend qu'un seul violon voix la plus
large mais un sol violon et passait ce
violon qui jouent ensemble et je vous je
vous suis cher
elle accélère la ville a le trac la
pression michel à la merci beaucoup
michel
alors on fait des on va débriefer qu'est
ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se passe
dans l'écouté dans la recherche
d'harmonisation qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est exactement comme quand vous
regardez un paysage au loin vous avez au
loin une église qui vous avez un grand
paysage et puis d'un seul coup vous avez
vous voulez voir un clocher et votre
oeil va s'adapter c'est l'ensemble de
votre organisme qui va faire que d'un
seul coup vous êtes distinguer voire
très bien ce détail que vous ne voyez
pas vous écoutez une symphonie vous
voulez entendre le hautbois qui joue
l'idée de ce tout près des plus perdu au
milieu de chants instruments et votre
oreille va aller mettre au point donc
c'est tout simplement le fait d'aller
écouter d'aller chercher une information
qui d'un seul coup c'est que votre corps
votre travail votre oreille vos sens et
cela apparaît et donc les coudes c'est
exactement la même chose là qu'est ce
que c'est ça veut dire c'est pas
seulement être avec michel ça veut dire
l'entendre ça veut dire modifier le son
parce qu'on doit avoir non seulement la
même vitesse on doit avoir la même
intention on doit avoir la même sonorité
le même timbre c'est à dire que
l'harmonisation n'est pas seulement
faire les choses ensemble c'est les
faire en intégrant l'ensemble des
paramètres qui sont le musculaire la
respiration la texture de la peau tout
ça sont des sons différents
si on est parfaitement ensemble
mais qu'on a des sons différents on ne
sera pas à harmoniser et la seule
manière d'harmoniser la plus simple
c'est tout simplement d'écouter
d'entendre et le corps fait alors on
joue bretons terminent par d'art de la
vraie musique on va donc ajouter au nord
sud à l'east west la verticalité la 7e
dub et or sur ce petit rythme de cette
allegretto qui fait tout ce début est
content je vous dirige maestro musique
china team papables un paravent
donc là vous suivez le chef vous écoutez
votre production collective et vous
écoutez b teuf
vous n'avez pas écouté des offres
zhu piano fait légèrement devant lui et
devant le chef
servez vous de vos oreilles pas que du
geste
faites entrer votre percussions
vous entendez cd contrebasse et
violoncelle qui font votre rythme
outre coûté le contrebasse
bon ben et fait sonner dans les
contrebasses
ça y est
retenue
retenu ce tellement meilleur un peu
retenu
et vous galoper les amis
un peu de tendresse
un peu au fond du temps
retenez l'intention
on
et ça se fond dans la musique
venez musiciens de leur quête aux
oreilles
montrer plus
dans leurs fiefs
via notte
mercy west
bravo